bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va pas
m de simone de beau
voir simone de beauvoir et
or française née en 1908
elle est connue comme étant l'une des
principales théoricienne du féminisme au
xxème siècle notamment à travers son
oeuvre
le deuxième sexe paru en 1949
c'est une philosophe qui a eu beaucoup
d'influencé dans l'histoire des idées
politiques contemporaines elle est l'une
des premières à avoir placé la question
du genre au coeur de ces analyses
même si elle n'utilise pas directement
ce terme dans son oeuvre
et si le féminisme de simone de beauvoir
mérite qu'on s'y arrête
c'est parce qu'il constitue le
prolongement d'une vision philosophique
beaucoup plus large
une vision philosophique qu'on appelle
l'existentialisme
et sur laquelle on va se pencher dans
cet épisode pour tenter de comprendre de
quelle féminisme nous parlons
en effet quand on parle du féminisme on
ne sait pas toujours exactement de quoi
il retourne
entre le féminisme libertaire le
féminisme intersectionnelle où le
féminisme différentialiste grande est la
tentation de voir dans ces subdivisions
du féminisme des querelles de clocher
mais en réalité on va voir que les
choses sont comme toujours un petit peu
plus complexe
et qu'il y a au fondement du féminisme
de simone de beauvoir une vision du
monde et de l'être humain qu'on peut
partager ou pas
mais qui a au moins le mérite d'éclairer
le sens profond de son engagement
avant d'analyser cette vision
philosophique qui est celle de simone de
beauvoir
il peut être intéressant de revenir sur
certains éléments de sa vie
non pas pour se livrer à des
interprétations psychologiques
hasardeuse on n'est pas là pour ça
parce que simone de beauvoir a elle même
relaté certains épisodes de sa jeunesse
comme ayant été déterminant dans la
construction de sa pensée
et l'un des épisodes les plus marquants
de sa jeunesse
c'est le jour où elle a pris conscience
qu'elle allait devoir devenir une femme
indépendante
alors replacer les choses dans leur
contexte
on est quelques années après la première
guerre mondiale le grand père maternel
de simone de beauvoir gustavo racer est
président d'une grande banque française
la banque de la meuse
et la banque fait faillite brasseur est
déclarée en banqueroute
cette banqueroute précipitera toute la
famille dans la ruine
les beauvoir qui habitait rue raspail à
paris sont contraints de déménager dans
un vieil appartement du 6e
arrondissement
puisqu'ils n'ont plus les moyens
d'assumer leurs anciens loyer
simone a une soeur hélène et les deux
jeunes filles voient le climat familial
se dégrader progressivement en même
temps que leur situation sociale
ce que vit à ce moment-là simone de
beauvoir c'est l'expérience du
déclassement et ce déplacement se fera
sentir dans sa chair quand son père lui
annoncera qu'elle et sa soeur serait
contrainte de travailler dur pour
subvenir à leurs besoins
alors il se trouve qu'à cette époque
simone de beauvoir à un rêve
celui de devenir écrivaine une écrivaine
célèbre dira-t-elle et d'une certaine
manière on peut dire que son expérience
du déclassement a transformé ce rêve en
ambition
il ne s'agissait plus d'un espoir il
s'agissait désormais d'une nécessité
nécessité de travailler pour s'élever
socialement
nécessité de lutter pour son
indépendance
ces sites est de gagner le respect et la
reconnaissance dans un monde
essentiellement gouvernée par des hommes
donc nourri par cette ambition qu après
son baccalauréat
simone de beauvoir entame des études
classiques lettres et mathématiques
elle obtient son certificat avant de
hantée vers une licence de philosophie
une discipline pour laquelle elle se
passionne
en 1929 elle fait la rencontre de jean
paul sartre elle a 20 ans il en a 22
cette rencontre
sartre sera déterminante dans la
trajectoire de simone de beauvoir
elle verra en lui un génie inspirant qui
sera d'abord pour elle un guide
devenir un compagnon
son amour nécessaire comme il le dira
lui-même plus tard pour qualifier leur
relation
sur le plan
fyk simone de beauvoir partage la vision
existentialiste de jean paul sartre et
c'est là qu'il va falloir rentrer un peu
dans le détail de cette pensée
existentialiste car comme je vous le
disais au début de cet épisode c'est
dans cette pensée que l'engagement
féministe de simone de beauvoir l'a
véritablement plonger ses racines
or qu'est-ce que l'existentialisme et la
définition la plus simple on puisse
donner de l'existentialisme
c'est en gros l'idée que l'être humain
est maître de sa destinée
pour être un peu plus précis
l'existentialisme c'est l'idée que
l'être humain ne possède pas une nature
prédéfinis une essence prédéfinis
au contraire il construit son essence il
construit son identité
il a construit au travers de ses choix
et de ses actions
en clair l'être humain n'est rien
d'autre que la somme de ses choix
pour ceux que ça intéresse
on trouve une présentation très facile
d'accès à ce courant de pensée dans le
petit livre de jean paul sartre intitulé
l'existentialisme est un humanisme qui
est à l'origine une conférence qu'il a
donnée en 1945
et dans cette conférence ça prend un
exemple très concret que tous les
professeurs de philosophie utilisent
pour expliquer l'existentialisme à leurs
élèves
c'est l'exemple du coupe papier
qu est ce qu un coupe-papier un coupe
papier nous lit sartre s'élabore un
objet qui a été fabriqué
c'est un objet qui a un créateur
jusque là
d'accord donc si on est d'accord avec ça
on sera aussi d'accord pour dire que ce
coupe papier avant d'avoir été fabriqué
il a d'abord été pensé par son créateur
d'abord été conçu dans l'esprit avant
d'être conçu dans la matière
et dire que le coup papier a été pensé
avant d'être créée
c'est dire que sa création répond à un
but
elle répond
sont celles de couper du papier
autrement dit un objet fabriqué c'est un
objet qui a une fonction
et cette fonction
on détermine son essence
on ne sait pas
arcis sartre prend l'exemple du coupe
papier parce qu'en l'occurrence le nom
de cet objet signale sa fonction
et en signalant sa fonction
signale son essence
et donc ce que nous dit sartre c'est que
dans le cas du coup papier
l'essence précède l'existence
l'essence précède existence autrement
dit la fonction pressait de la
fabrication
parce que s'il n'avait pas de fonction
le coupe-papier n'aurait littéralement
aucune raison d'être
parce qu'il n'y a aucun intérêt à
fabriquer un objet pour ensuite se
demander à quoi il pourrait servir
ça paraît logique donc dans le cas des
objets des objets fabriqués l'essence
précède l'existence
or ce que nous dit l'existentialisme
c'est que s'agissant de l'être humain ce
n'est pas l'essence qui précède
l'existence
c'est au contraire l'existence qui
précède l'essence qu'est ce que ça veut
dire
bien ça veut dire que contrairement à un
objet fabriqué
rue main n'a pas de créateurs
donc s'il n'a pas de créateurs il n'a
pas de fonction pré défini par son
créateur
s'il n'a pas de fonction
d'essence il n'a pas d'essence puisqu'il
est libre de choisir son essence
et donc la conséquence de
l'existentialisme sais que parler d'une
essence de l'homme ou d'une nature de
l'homme ça n'a pas de sens
parce que ces présupposés qu'il
existerait en amont de notre existence
un projet qui donnerait un sens
particulier à notre existence
mais
qui serait l'auteur de ce projet
dieu oui c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'existentialisme
chrétien et sauf que l'existentialisme
de sartre et de beauvoir est un
existentialisme athée c'est un
existentialisme fondée sur l'idée qu'il
n'existe pas de créateur du genre humain
etc c'est justement pour ça qu'il est
vain de rechercher une essence de
l'homme
la seule essence de l'homme c'est sa
liberté
c'est le fait qu'il soit lui même
l'auteur de son essence
et renier cette liberté en cherchant à
définir une prétendue nature humaine
c'est ce que ça te rappelle la mauvaise
foi
donc quand l'existentialisme dit que la
vie humaine n'a pas de sens c'est pour
dire que le sens de la vie n'est pas à
rechercher dans un haut de la
métaphysique
lorsque neil chapelet un arrière monde
propre subjectivité
entre propres
existence au monde
le sens de notre vie c'est nous qui l'
construisons
et nous le construisons parce que nous
possédons une conscience que cette
conscience fait de nous des sujets et
non des objets et que le propre d'un
sujet c'est d'être l'inventeur de son
destin
quand on demande à quoi un objet destiné
on demande quelle est son utilité
quel est son but c'est ça le destin d'un
objet son but mais s'agissant de l'homme
son but c'est de se destiner c'est de
choisir son destin
donc c'est ça l'idée maîtresse de
l'existentialisme l'idée que l'être
humain choisi son destin
destin c'est quelque chose de très
concret choisir son destin c'est choisir
l'environnement dans lequel on veut
évoluer c'est choisir la situation à
laquelle on veut accéder
on peut choisir d'être écrivain c'est le
choix que fera simone de beauvoir on
peut choisir d'être boulanger être car
son cas fait d'être banquier c'est nous
qui décidons
c'est nous qui l'incarnons notre projet
existentielle
et même s'il est évident que chacune de
ces options est plus ou moins
difficilement atteignable
selon notre milieu d'origine selon notre
situation sociale
selon la pression de l'environnement
ce que nous dit l'existentialisme c'est
que ces options
elles existent ne sommes pas condamnés à
être ce que notre environnement a fait
de nous
il ya une phrase de sartre qui résume
assez bien les choses il dit l'important
n'est pas ce qu'on a fait de nous mais
ce qu'on fait de ce qu'on a fait de nous
tout est dit quand on veut
quel existentialisme
qui reviennent le plus consiste à dire
que c'est une philosophie qui ne tient
pas compte des déterminismes sociaux
c'est d'ailleurs ce que reprocheront à
sartre certains auteurs marxiste
comme georg lukacs elle pas confondre
avec le réalisateur qui dira que
l'existentialisme est en réalité le
nouveau masque philosophique de la
bourgeoisie
puisque l'existentialisme ne se
préoccupe plus des structures économico
sociale mais se portent uniquement sur
la conscience de l'individu
c'est pas faux
c'est pas faux mais ce que disent les
existentialistes ce n'est pas que les
structures économico sociale n'existe
pas ils ne disent pas que nous ne sommes
soumis à aucune influence ni à aucun
déterminisme
qu'ils disent
l'être humain n'est pas un objet et si
l'être humain n'est pas un objet c'est
parce qu étant dotés d'une conscience
condamné à suivre passivement le flux de
ses déterminations
parce qu'alors qu'est ce qui nous
différencie des objets à chaque fois que
nous nous donnons une identité à chaque
fois que nous donnons une essence
c'est nous qui nous donnant cette
essence
on aura beau tourner le problème dans
tous les sens le fait est que si notre
essence se définit par nos actions nous
avons le pouvoir de définir notre
essence
à chaque instant
et ce n'est pas parce que le bateau ait
poussé par les courants marins que
capitaine ne tient pas son gouvernail
c'est justement malgré les courants
marins que capitaine peut définir la
trajectoire de son bateau en fonction de
son projet est la destination que s'est
fixés
c'est ça le principe de
l'existentialisme la conscience humaine
et le gouvernail par lequel nous
dirigeons notre existence
alors au terme de
développement sur l'existentialisme vous
serez en droit de me dire ok
et quelle race
avec le féminisme parce que c'est bien
beau de théoriser sur le fait que l'être
humain n'a pas d'essence mais
concrètement on ne voit pas très bien ce
que ça a à voir avec le féminisme
bien ce que ça à voir c'est très simple
c'est que si
pas d'essence si c'est l'être humain
lui-même qui définit son essence eh bien
ça veut dire qu'ils n'existent pas plus
décence humaine qu'il n'existe descente
féminine
en d'autres termes la féminité comme la
masculinité
ça n'existe pas alors là évidemment on
arrive
sujet et si j'ai voulu prendre le temps
de revenir sur ce qu'est
l'existentialisme c'est pour vous
montrer à quel point le féminisme
défendu par simone de beauvoir en
découlent de façon logique
car la caractéristique de ce féminisme
c'est qu'il repose philosophiquement sur
ce qu'on appelle un anti essentialisme
l'essentialisme c'est le fait
d'attribuer aux choses des propriétés
naturelles est immuable
c'est dire par exemple qu'il existerait
une nature féminine
un éternel féminin
autrement dit que la féminité ne serait
pas quelque chose de culturel mais dîner
et d'intemporel
donc si vous avez bien suivi ce qu'on a
dit jusqu'à présent vous aurez compris
que l'essentialisme c'est tout ce que
simone de beauvoir rejette
elle ne peut que le rejeter car pour
l'existentialisme c'est nous et
seulement nous qui détermineront notre
essence
je disais en préambule de cet épisode
qu'il existait plusieurs branches du
féminisme
le féminisme existentialiste étant l'une
de ses branches
mais à l'opposé du spectre on trouve ce
qu'on appelle le féminisme
différentialiste
qui lui part du principe qu'il existe
une nature féminine
le féminisme différentialiste c'est un
courant qui considère qu'il existe des
attributs intrinsèquement féminin et qui
milite pour leur valorisation dans
l'espace social
féminisme différentialiste c'est donc un
féminisme qui considèrent non seulement
qu'il existe des différences entre les
hommes et les femmes mais surtout et
c'est ça le plus important que ces
différences ne sont pas seulement
d'ordre social qu'elles ne sont pas
seulement des constructions culturelles
mais qu'elle relève de l'ine
différences biologiques notamment
physiologique et hormonales
différences psychologiques
selon l'idée que l'avis du cor
déterminent la vie de l'esprit
différences comportementales elle même
consécutive aux différences
psychologiques
revanche ce que conteste le féminisme
différentialiste c'est le principe de
hiérarchisation entre les attributs
masculins et les attributs féminins
c'est l'idée que la nature féminine
devrait être considérée comme inférieure
à la nature masculine
c'est ça que le féminisme
différentialiste rejette l'idée qu'une
différence de genre devrait induire une
différence de valeur
donc ce qui pose problème aux féministes
différentialiste s'était pas qu'on dise
qu'il y a des différences entre les
hommes et les femmes
c'est que ce constat conduise à
l'établissement d'une hiérarchie de
valeurs entre la féminité et la
masculinité
ce qui leur pose problème c'est qu'au
lieu de valoriser la féminité pour en
faire une essence de valeur égale à la
masculinité
on cherche à la dissoudre et à la faire
oublier dans l'imitation de la
masculinité
ce qui leur pose problème c'est que sous
couvert de défense des femmes
on s'attaque finalement à ce qui fait
l'essence des femmes à savoir la
féminité car penser que pour être les
égales des hommes les femmes devraient
renoncer à être des femmes
n'est ce pas se soumettre aux critères
de valeur de la masculinité
n'est ce pas considérer qu'il est
valorisant d'être un homme est honteux
d'être une femme
donc voyez ici qu'on est très très loin
du féminisme existentialiste défendu par
simone de beauvoir
on en est même à l'opposé
et vous voyez aussi que cette opposition
elle tient d'abord à une divergence
philosophique
on n'a pas affaire ici un conflit
d'opinion
on a affaire à un différend métaphysique
et quand je parle de différents
métaphysique pour bien comprendre qu'on
est en train de parler
on est en train de parler de la querelle
des universaux
la chorale des universaux c'est le grand
débat philosophique y ait lieu de
l'antiquité au moyen âge qui débute avec
platon et aristote
sur le fait de savoir si les universaux
c'est à dire les essences sont bel et
bien des réalités qui existent
indépendamment de nous ou bien si ce
sont seulement des constructions de
notre esprit
le cas qui nous occupe si je parle de la
femme et de l'homme
la question est de savoir est-ce que je
sous-entend qu'il existe une essence
féminine et une essence masculine
éternel dans les femmes et les hommes
seraient les représentants incarner
ou bien est-ce que j'emploie ce mot par
simple commodité de langage tout en
estimant par ailleurs qu'il ne s'agit là
que de construction culturelle nos
renvoyant à aucune réalité consistante
donc vous voyez que ça va très loin on
n'est pas du tout
une querelle politique
on dans une querelle ontologique
et simone de beauvoir elle a choisi son
camp ontologique
son camp ontologique c'est
l'existentialisme c'est le rejet d
essence c'est le rejet d'un éternel
féminin mythique et fantasmée dans
lequel elle ne voit qu'une tentative par
les hommes de figer des femmes dans une
essence pour ainsi pouvoir mieux les
maîtriser et les inférioriser
l'éternel féminin c'est la tentative de
définir et de s'emparer de ce qui relève
fondamentalement de l'indéfinissable et
de l'insaisissable
et si la nature féminine est
insaisissable ce n'est pas en vertu
d'une qualité mystique
c'est parce que c'est l'être humain
lui-même qui est insaisissable
c'est parce que c'est la nature même de
l'être humain de ne pouvoir être saisi
étant donné que sa nature c'est la
liberté c'est à dire leur rejet de toute
détermination
et en figeant les femmes dans une
essence féminine dans un éternel féminin
mythique
on allait rendre possible l'attribution
aux femmes de fonctions prétendument
naturel
et ce faisant
leur interdire l'accès à l'expérience
humaine la plus haute à savoir
la liberté je cite tout le monde
s'accorde
être qu'il y a dans l'espèce humaine des
femelles elle constitue aujourd'hui
comme autrefois à peu près la moitié de
l'humanité
et pourtant on nous dit que la féminité
est en péril on nous exhorte
soyez femme restée femmes
devenez fan
femelle n'est donc pas nécessairement
une femme
il faut participer à cette réalité
mystérieuse est menacée qu'est la
féminité
celle-ci est-elle sécrétée par les
ovaires ou figées au fond d'un ciel
platonicien suffit d'un jupon à
froufrous pour la faire descendre sur
terre
bien que certaines femmes ses forces
avec celles de l'incarner le modèle n'en
a jamais été déposé
on la décrit volontiers en termes vagues
et miroitant qui semble emprunté au
vocabulaire des voyantes autant de saint
thomas
elle apparaissait comme une essence
aussi sûrement défini que la vertu dormi
tive du pavot
mais le conceptualisme a perdu du
terrain les sciences biologiques et
social ne croient plus en l'existence
d'entités immuablement fixée
s'il n'ya plus aujourd'hui féminité
c'est qu'il n'y en a jamais yeux
le féminisme existentialiste
féminisme anti essentialiste
c'est un féminisme qui refuse de
considérer que les rôles sociaux
attribués aux femmes et aux hommes
découlerait d'une essence primitive
domicilié dans une nature éternelle ou
dans un haut de la métaphysique
la critique de simone de beauvoir est
donc très clair
c'est la critique de la naturalisation
des rôles sociaux
qu'est ce qu'un rôle social
et bien c'est par exemple la femme au
foyer la femme au foyer étant le
prolongement culturels de la femme
biologique
de la femme conçu comme matrix
c'est à dire de la femme physiquement
inféodés à l'homme et aux dépendances de
la maternité
un rôle social c'est par exemple le chef
de famille
le chef de famille étant là encore le
prolongement culturel du chef de tribu
qui organise l'appropriation des
ressources ainsi que la défense et la
conquête du territoire et donc dénoncer
la naturalisation des rôles sociaux
c'est dénoncer le fait que parce qu'il
existe des différences biologiques entre
les sexes
ces différences biologiques devrait se
traduire dans des différences de
fonction
or pour simone de beauvoir
lien entre attributs naturels et
fonction sociale n'a pas lieu d'être
au lieu d'être parce que cela
reviendrait à introduire l'idée que les
êtres humains possèderait une essence
m'ont dit qu'ils ne seraient pas libres
de choisir leur essence
donc là encore tout ramène à
l'existentialisme et à son rejet des
essences et si vous avez compris à quel
point l'idée d'indépendance à l'égard
des déterminations naturel constitue le
centre de gravité de la pensée
existentialiste alors vous avez compris
du même coup le sens de l'engagement
féministe de simone de beauvoir
le rejet de tout et détermination pour
simone de beauvoir
contrairement aux animaux
main ont la capacité de dévier de leur
trajectoire naturelle
ils ont la capacité de construire leur
identité à l'encontre de ce que la
nature a prévu pour eux
c'est ce qu'on appelle la civilisation
la civilisation c'est le projet
historique de l'humanité
s'émanciper des contraintes de la nature
c'est le projet d'humanité de définir sa
propre essence
et au cours de l'histoire l'humanité à
développer quelque chose de
particulièrement performant pour
l'assister dans ce projet à savoir la
technique
la technique c'est ce qui nous a franchi
du biologique
c'est ce qui nous a franchi
impératif de l'espèce or pour simone de
beauvoir nos sociétés technicisé devrait
tendre vers ce projet d'émancipation
vis-à-vis du biologique
elle devrait tendre vers une des animals
isation de notre condition
elle devrait le faire premièrement parce
qu'elles le peuvent
et deuxièmement parce que notre
animalité et toujours vectrices d'une
infériorisation du rôle des femmes
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que notre
animalité est vectrice d'une
infériorisation du rôle des femmes
bien ça veut dire que d'un point de vue
et animale
d'un point de vue biologique
le rôle de l'homme et productif
tandis que le rôle de la femme et
reproductifs
l'homme créé la femme procréent et c'est
cette dissymétrie originel qui est la
source
selon simone de beauvoir de
l'infériorisation du statut des femmes
car ce que remarque simone de beauvoir
c'est que la nature animale de l'homme
le destine à l'indépendance
dit que la nature animale de la femme
la destine à la dépendance
biologiquement la femme incarne la
passivité et l'intériorité tandis que
l'homme incarne l'activité et
l'extériorité la femme est physiquement
plus faible que l'homme elle est donc
dépendante de lui du point de vue de la
survie
est vouée à rester au foyer où elle est
en sécurité
l'homme s'est au contraire celui qui
sort du foyer pour chasser rapporté la
nourriture
éventuellement pour se battre afin de
défendre le territoire
la femme porte et donne le sein à ses
enfants ce qui accentue sa vulnérabilité
aux agressions extérieures
et donc sa dépendance à l'égard de
l'homme
al'inverse l'homme n'est biologiquement
rattachés à ces enfants que par un jet
de semences
ce qui lui confère une plus grande
indépendance
sexuellement la femme reçoit en elle le
sexe masculin
la sexualité féminine est donc lié à
l'intériorité
et et masculine est marqué par l'acte de
pénétration
phallus représentant la conquête alors
que le mot utérus signifie
étymologiquement le ventre
encore une fois l'intérêt
rites et donc c'est ce rapport
d'inégalité biologique entre les femmes
et les hommes
le fait que du point de vue de la survie
de l'espèce la féminité débouche sur une
situation de dépendance
tandis que la masculinité débouche sur
l'indépendance que simone de beauvoir
perçoit comme une atteinte au principe
de l'existentialisme
l'existentialisme on l'a suffisamment
répété
c'est l'affranchissement à l'égard de
toutes les déterminations extérieur
c'est la construction d'un projet
individuel qui ne soit pas arrivé à
notre condition biologique ou un autre
situation sociale
or ce que simone de beauvoir nous dit
c'est que dans ce projet existentielle
l'homme est naturellement favoriser par
rapport à la femme
parce que la nature même de son
animalité le prédispose à sortir de son
animalité
elle le prédispose à surpasser ses
déterminations biologique
l'animalité masculine c'est la conquête
c'est l'appropriation
c'est le façonnement du monde
l'animalité masculine c'est la nécessité
d'aller en permanence au delà de soi
c'est-à-dire de transcender constamment
sa condition l'animalité masculine c'est
le mouvement tandis que l'animalité
féminine
c'est au contraire leurs prix dans
l'intériorité
c'est la fragilité la peur du monde
extérieur
c'est la fixité
quand l'animalité de l'homme le pousse à
la transcendance l'animalité de la femme
la rive al-iman ans
simone de beauvoir à une phrase pour ça
elle dit le malheur de la femme c'est
d'avoir été biologiquement voué à
répéter la vie
la femme répète la vie
quand l'homme face
seule la ville c'est la distinction
on trouve dans l'île les morphisme la
métaphysique d'aristote entre le
principe de la matière et le principe de
la forme
un peu comme la sculpture nécessite à la
fois une matière à sculpter et le
travail du sculpteur
matière étant associé à la femme créée
la vie
de la forme est associée à l'homme qui
façonnent le monde
et donc le fait que la femme soit
biologiquement condamnés à répéter la
vie au lieu de la façonner
c'est quelque chose que simone de
beauvoir refuse
elle le refuse au nom de l'idée que la
civilisation
ce n'est pas le prolongement de la
biologie mais le dépassement de la
biologie
ce que voudrait simone de beauvoir c'est
que dans des sociétés où les attributs
masculins et féminins n'ont plus de
signification du point de vue de la
survie de l'espèce puisque la
mécanisation de la production a permis
de se libérer du besoin de la force de
travail masculine et que la baisse de la
mortalité infantile ne rend plus
nécessaire de faire beaucoup d'enfants
pour reproduire l'espèce
que dans ses sociétés les femmes et les
hommes ne soit plus associé à des rôles
mais deviennent ce que le projet
existentialiste considèrent qu'ils
doivent devenir à savoir des individus
libres
des individus libres porteurs de projets
existentielle c'est à dire porteur de
projet qui dépasse les contraintes liées
à la reproduction de l'espèce
pour simone de beauvoir hommes et femmes
doivent tendre à une égalité sociale qui
est le seul lieu possible de la liberté
humaine
je cite tout sujet se pose concrètement
à travers des projets comme une
transcendance il n'accomplit sa liberté
que par son perpétuel déplacement vers
d'autres libertés
il n'y a d'autre justification de
l'existence présente que son expansion
vers un avenir indéfiniment ouvert
chaque fois que la transcendance retombe
en immanence il y a
dégradation de l'existence en en soi
peu la liberté en facticité
cette chute est une faute morale c'est
lé consentis par le sujet
ça lui est infligée elle prend la figure
d'une frustration et d'une oppression
elle est dans les deux cas un mal absolu
vie du qui a le souci de justifier son
existence épreuve celle ci comme un
besoin indéfinie de se transcender
or ce qui définit d'une manière
singulière la situation de la femme
c'est que étant comme tout être humain
une liberté autonome elle se découvre et
se choisit dans un monde où les hommes
lui impose de s'assumer comme l'autre
on prétend la fij et en objets et
l'avouer à l'immanence puisque sa
transcendance sera perpétuellement
transcendé par une autre conscience est
essentielle et souveraine
le drame de la femme c'est ce conflit
entre la revendication fondamentale de
tout sujet qui s'opposent toujours comme
l'essentiel et les exigences d'une
situation qui la constituent comines est
essentielle
comment dans la condition féminine peut
s'accomplir un être humain
quelle voix lui sont ouvertes
les qu'elles aboutissent à des impasses
comment retrouver l'indépendance au sein
de la dépendance
quelles circonstances limite la liberté
de la femme et peut-elle l'été passé
ce sont là les questions fondamentales
que nous voudrions élucidées
c'est dire que nous intéressant aux
chances de l'individu nous ne définiront
pas ses chances en termes de bonheur
mais en termes de libertés
si l'être humain
d'essence si la seule
de l'être humain
liberté m
sa liberté par laquelle il construit son
projet existentielle
on peut légitimement se demander
dre cette liberté si elle ne rencontrait
aucun obstacle
que votre
libertine si elle n'était
à une réponse lorsque simone de beauvoir
forme dans son esprit son projet
d'indépendance
sans projet
sion à l'égard de la fatalité sociale
elle le fait en réaction
une situation
subi
échappé aux
on se rebeller contre les essences un
tel projet resteraient vains si nous ne
rencontrions pas
sur notre parcours est l'adversaire à
vaincre le parados
certaines séquelles a besoin d'un
adversaire à vaincre la liberté de
moeurs
eu un mot creux si elle n'était pas
confronté à son autre
la limite et si c'est bel et bien
mythe ce qui rend peu
cible la liberté si c'est bel et bien
l'obstacle à la liberté
sa valeur à la liberté
alors la question qui se pose à nous est
de savoir
et le destin de l'homme libre
s'ils n'avaient rien à conquérir
je vous remercie
[Musique]